but first up Columbia where a well-known
dance company is working to further the
process of reconciliation in this
violent conflict ridden country
step by step toward reconciliation the
choreography in sealeo is dedicated to
the victims of terrorism in Colombia
uncounted dead and millions of refugees
within the country after Sudan Colombia
is the country with the most internal
refugees in the world the city of
Medellin was once the bastion of drug
cartels today culture is returning 150
refugees from all over Colombia are part
of the dance project in Celia the idea
came from choreographer Alvaro Restrepo
Helio es una ceremonia Inc Celia is a
ceremony a homage to the victims of the
armed conflict in Colombia so far five
million nine hundred thousand people
have lost their homes we can speak of a
parallel country of people in difficult
situations displaced people who have
lost their rights their paradise was
there a truth Colombia is rich in
natural resources but for 50 years since
the 1960s guerrilla groups like the FARC
paramilitary groups and the army have
been fighting caught in the middle are
the citizens tyrannize terrorized and
brutally driven from their homes but
recently the government and the FARC
have begun negotiating an end to the
fighting the [ __ ] told everyone in the
village yet my father was killed when my
mother was three months pregnant
with just my life and my children let's
fire paramilitaries the FARC and the
army all fight over the territory they
don't think about the people sadly it's
us the poorest we who live in the
countryside who suffer from it Celia we
commemorate these things but we also
want to think about how we look ahead
and how life continues
remembrance and hope the rehearsal
process is a catharsis healing old
wounds the peace process and national
reconciliation are the goal and the
dancers also want to shake colombians
awake to that purpose they stand
together on the stage the victims of
displacement and 30 professional dancers
for mystery pose dance school
the Colicchio de cuerpo the College of
the body started as a social project in
1997 it's now one of Columbia's most
renowned dance schools a curricular
opportunity to show collected el cuerpo
is a school of life and Vaart we want to
give children and young people from
difficult situations a chance if they
learn to love art they're less
susceptible to the dangers and bad
influences but young people are exposed
to in this country la semaine haces que
tienen los ninos ahora en este pais no
Maya Lucinda Ricardo entered the dance
school when they were children now
they're world-class dancers working
people's barrio in Cartagena named
Nelson Mandela it's a neighborhood with
conflicts and gangs and a pretty weak
economy I was fortunate to have the
chance to escape through the Colegio Ted
clinicals to learn a lot and discover
new things outside of the life in the
body okay en el barrio this is what
these societal flashpoints the Barrios
look like they're still impoverished
ruled by gangs and dangerous Maya listen
Ricardo dream of a new safe Colombia
Galatia del cuerpo
is an institution where we work with
dance not just as an art form but also
as a way of improving people and society
a project like in Sileo is born out of
this concept this philosophical idea
in Colombia and internationally the
project has been successful with
audiences and critics it sends an
important signal
estamos we're experiencing a moment of
hope because a new peace process began a
few months ago we hope it will end this
conflict which has raged for much too
long more than 50 years now he
Colombians should realize but we can
build a country where we can all live in
peace and by easing bus but atolls and
so the college of the body will continue
to perform exceeding Colombia and Brazil
are the two most powerful economies in
Latin America an end to the conflict
could fuel further development this fall
the company will go on tour through
Europe to dance its vision of a new
peaceful Colombia